et bonjour comment ça va alors
aujourd'hui on se parle de quoi on se
pare d'un nouveau smartphone c'est le
nord 70 ch en train de filmer avec tout
de suite et surtout j'ai pris un petit
micro pour optimiser la qualité et je
vais vous montrer dans cette vidéo on va
tester la qualité du micron va tester la
vidéo on va tout et c'est donc
aujourd'hui on se parle de ces honneurs
face on dit ce qui est présenté
officiellement dans deux jours donc le
hyper rien filer caché là directement
dans tout va bien se passer on va
regarder la performance on va regarder
s'il est bien regarder les différents
modes ya très gros focus qui a été fait
au niveau de la vidéo de la photo et
sans apparat dans une prochaine vidéo
sur les différents modes et notamment le
solo cadres dont qin et vous abonner
s'est pas déjà le cas comme ça vous
saurez tout et puis la 11e' dans berlin
ont fait des photos on se balade on est
bien donc vous êtes prêt on se parle
aujourd'hui du au nord 70 nouveaux
smartphones des eaux nord et vous allez
voir franchement il est vachement bien
[Musique]
le odeurs soixante dix il est là il est
beau il est frais regarder j'aime bien
ce design j'aime bien cette couleur il
existe soit anvers est vert émeraude je
crois soit en noir je préfère largement
et de très loin cette couleur que je
trouve hyper hyper jolie pour la boîte
quand elle allait tout est beaucoup plus
classique a pas grand chose à raconter
le seul truc qui à savoir au niveau de
la boîte et je pense ça va vous
intéresser c'est que ici au nord a fait
le choix de conserver le bloc de charge
donc si vous l'achetez vous avez un
album de charge de 66 moins-6 y est
inclus avec et c'est pas con l'idée de
laisser ce bloc de charge parce que
comme il ya plein de plein de marques
qu'ils suppriment et qu'il ne mette pas
ce qu'il le met et bien ils ont un
avantage concurrentiel parce que les
gens se dit j'ai pas besoin d'aller
acheter un bloc de charges en plus j'ai
bloc de charte qui est optimisé pour
j'ai dû 66 watts ça va vite c'est
pratique ça me va bien et ça c'est mal
l'odeur soixante dix ans martin qui est
pas très lourd il fait à peine 100 78
grammes vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui situé sous
l'écran juste la garde et on pose le
doigt et des verrous très très
rapidement on a une très grande dalle et
surtout on a un écran incurvé regarder
qui est incurvé légèrement sur le côté
je sais pas si vous aimez bien vous les
écrans incurvés mais je trouve sympa il
ya vraiment une profondeur ici c'est à
l'écran oled soit un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz et surtout
ses 1 120 hertz adaptative c'est à dire
qu'il va venir s'adapter vous serez pas
tout le temps sans verre vous pourrez
switcher en 61 90 m et finir sera de 120
hertz lorsque vos applications
nécessiteront on est une diagonale de 6
à 12 67 pouces résolution full hd 1
milliard de couleurs et un espace
colorimétrique 100% dci p3o taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 3 100 hertz
et les certifier hdr disent plus autant
vous dire que c'est au nom 70 il en a
sous le capot maintenant il a un défaut
à défaut majeur un défaut que je ne gêne
pas surtout vu positionnement tarifaire
c'est qu'en fait vous avez un haut
parleur mono vous avez uniquement le
haut parleur qui la qui marche le haut
parleur que vous avez la serre juste
pour vos appels et ne servira pas si
bien que lorsque vous prenez votre
smartphone comme ça voyez le bloquer et
y'a plus rien qui sort alors le problème
le vrai de désagréments vous allez avoir
ici c'est que on va manquer cette image
stéréo lorsque vous avez votre
smartphone dans les mains que vous
regardez des films des séries que vous
jouez à des jeux et ça je trouve ça
quand même pas ouf et dommage sur un
smartphone a quasiment 550 euros alors
rassurez vous ment il ya d'ubuntu 5.2
dont peu de vira père et un casque sans
fil très facilement ici pas de prise
jack dont bon de toute façon j'imagine
qu'on est plus utilisé avec des
écouteurs mais c'est vrai que comme il
est fait là je trouve que c'est un truc
qui est un peu dommage à côté de ça ça
sera soigné performant des cartes un
dragon
778 j'ai lu ce gpo gaming plus il est au
delà il en fait un peu plus à ces
pratiques on a 8 gigas de ram et on a
soit 128 juillet de stockage soit 256 et
cheonan il ya toujours une optimisation
logiciel c'est le gpu turbo x qui va
permettre de mieux gérer tout ce qui va
être affichage on a une batterie kapil
800 millions terreur qui vous permettra
de tenir une journée et demie voire deux
jours et comme je vous le disais vous
avez de la recharge rapide 66 watts donc
il va venir faire charger rapidement
donc la question d'autonomie pour on
s'en fout un petit peu dans la mesure où
c'est pas des conneries voyez une
journée demi on a ce qu'il faut côté
logiciel on m a dit qu à six points qui
est basé sur un android 12 alors j'aime
bien cette version logicielle parce que
vous avez tous ces codes couleurs qui
sont très pratique on sort faire très
facilement vous avez des séparations
pour comprendre réellement comment c'est
fait il ya plein de petites options
c'est plutôt bien fait comme on est basé
sur android ou d'un matériel you donc
franchement belle expérience qui est
très très bonne et que je trouve très
cohérente aujourd'hui avec un thème
clair un thème sombre un mode confort
des yeux même si fatalement beau ça
donne une couleur qui est pas très très
belle vous le mettez au minimum parce
que là au delà c'est vraiment pas jolie
plein de fond d'écran on peut venir un
personnalisé choisir également venir
choisir ses icônes et évidemment tous
les paramètres biométrique
reconnaissance faciale capteur
d'empreintes digitales bref c'est
complet ça marche bien et vous allez ce
qu'il faut mais là où on aura fait un
très gros focus sur toute la partie
photo vidéo vous avez pas moins 3
capteur à l'arrière vous élaborez
capteur principal 54 mégapixels couvre f
1.8 c'est la toute nouvelle sony mx
puissant par le crac capter beaucoup
plus de lumière on un très grand capteur
vous avez également un ultra grand angle
122 degré et ma croix 2.5 cm avec un
autofocus avec un capteur 50 méga pixels
tous vos rêves de points depuis vous
avez un petit capteur de profondeur qui
est situé par la 2 mégapixels f 2.4 sans
oublier une caméra de cette fille de 30
2 mégapixels alors j'ai fait des photos
plein de photos de tous les côtés et je
trouve que le rendu mon bien et que là
dessus au nord a bien bossé capteur
principal l'ultra grand angle on sort
des choses très bien on peut venir vous
mais un petit peu je vais vous montrer
parce qu'une vraie cohérence je trouve
que même entre le grand-angle et l'ultra
grand pang et une cohérence
colorimétrique et qui s'ils ont bien
bossé voyez on est sur un contre jour on
a le soleil qui est juste là et pour
autant et bien on voit bien les feuilles
yann est cramé je fais petite balade à
droite à gauche jallet voit que c'est
très très cool j'ai également enchaîné
avec des photos de nuit alors je vous
montre quelques petites photos de nuit
je trouve que soit la nuit aussi s'en
sort vachement bien là sur l'autel pas
de souci la façade est là la gestion des
lumières est très bonne et là dessus on
voit que au nord a vraiment bossé au
niveau algorithmique pour vous proposer
quelque chose qui m'a vachement bien et
les photos de nuit sont bien alors c'est
pas le meilleur appareil pour les photos
nuit très clairement il faudra monter en
gamme davantage pour avoir ce qui est
mieux mais déjà on voit que ce capteur
la lit et mixe lui s'en est fait le taff
elle ne s'est vraiment bien et elle a
pas rouge il ya donc si vous voulez de
très bonnes photos de nuit avec ce
capteur chauffe que ça marche deux jours
aussi sont les contre-jours voyait la
façade et là ça fonctionne ya un vrai
boulot logiciel or là il a eu un peu
plus de main sur l'ultra grand angle
notre côté je le gagne coller le soleil
en panne tranche non non ça marche
prouve que dans l'ensemble c'est
vachement bien là encore peut-être
d'autres mises à jour logicielles qui
viendront encore améliorer l'histoire
voyez lorsqu'on vient trop tôt mais il
ya un moment il ya un peu plus de mal
ici là mais sinon le job jobs est bien
fait tout ça bien maîtrisé avec toute
cette partie là étaient cramés lorsque
j'ai prise la photo et pour autant
lorsqu'on voit le résultat comme ça ça
ne l'est pas donc bien la caméra de elle
fit aussi je trouve bonne le rendu
correct et marche bien la jolie
ministation un petit peu plus difficile
avec un côté contre jour dont bon
forcément ça bien si nous ressortir
visage grâce à l'algorithme bon ça fait
le taf là ces photos elle est
intéressante parce qu'en fait quand ce
que j'ai pris la photo tout était cramé
ici et là c'est les plus crâne est
pareil sur le grand-angle et luttera
grand-angle donc pour moi ici en termes
de photos on a un appareil qui marche
bien un appareil qui n'a rien à envier
aux autres et même sur la macro en
général j'aime pas trop la macro mais là
comme l'est sur un capteur de 50 méga
pixels on a va faire des choses beaucoup
mieux garder leurs notes bien le détail
au niveau de la feuille on peut se
rapprocher jusqu'à 2,5 cm un nom qu'on
aime être beaucoup plus près de l'objet
là c'est pareil à côté doux et soyeux
garder la sq même pas mal petites fleurs
on vient se rapprocher on a du détail
alors après il faut venir trouver la
position des fois c'est pas évident et
quand les fleurs bull c'est le bazar
donc défendre un peu de mal loyer c'est
un peu flou mais là je les ai chopé
celle là et je trouve je trouve pas mal
alors c'est plus un effet whaou qu'un
truc de dingue mais c'est pas mal encore
une petite caméra de sel fil avec le
soleil en pleine tronche de lumière et
un peu plus du mais ça marche avec le
ciel au dessus ça marche regardez-la
cette fleur à la main et la jambe
éloignées sur un mode macro je me suis
rapproché j'ai du détail là j'aime bien
celle là je trouve très o'leary là c'est
pareil sur des pétales ya un côté très
soyeux et très doux j'aime bien aussi
c'est de couleurs lors avec les petits
reflet plus colorée en orange est très
jolie donc dans l'ensemble ça marche
quand même vachement bien et ici on voit
qu'effectivement au nord a vachement
bien bossé d'un point de vue logiciel
d'un point de vue algorithmique pour
travailler pour améliorer ça avec de
bons capteurs derrière et la performance
on allait planète ils sont alignés pour
vous au sortir de très jolies photos de
jour comme de nuit là vous allez
différents modes de vidéos la
chanterelle film effectivement avec
aplomb à rien j'ai enlevé le mon micro
pour regarder vraiment le micro du
smartphone donc là on est comme ça et on
s'attend que switcher sur l'ultra grand
temps fatalement ça met plus large ça
c'est très pratique lorsque vous le dire
vous filmer comme ça que vous retenez
juste
c'est bien ça vous évite d'avoir le
smartphone trop loin et des loyers micro
sans fois deux puits encore on peut
venir monte monte monte monte monte et
on va jusqu'à un maximum on y est
presque deux fois 6 t on au sud coréen
est celle fille alors ici par contre on
est filmé uniquement en 1080p 24 cas ici
ouais bon la qualité sera un peu moins
bonnes tout en sachant quand même que le
capteur était obsédé par rapport au nord
50 donc en termes de qualité on a quand
même ce qu'il faut donc l'interface que
je vous montre vous à remote mode vidéo
tient là vous avez votre mode photo qui
est là moi ce que je lis reprocher ses
succès contre intuitif que vous avez en
bas bruit pour pas qu'ils sont ultra
grand-angle ce que nous cherchons à
gauche au lieu de le mettre à droite et
puis ici pour me résous mais bon ça
c'est du point de détail me direz vous
le fameux mode portrait le mode clichés
nocturne un mot d'ouverture bon si vous
utilisez mais pourquoi pas le mode vidéo
sur lequel on était les modes multi
vidéo qui vous avez après mode super
macro vous avez le mode solo cup revient
à utiliser qu'il y aura plus de
personnes il faut être moins à quatre à
mettre des gens max entre 3 et 4 mètres
mais bon là il ya personne donc je vais
rien vous montrer aujourd'hui là dessus
et puis ensuite vous allez c'est très
simple filigrane ralenti le haut
voilà on va voir un mode multi vidéo où
je vais être d'un côté ou de l'autre
alors après je peux venir changer avant
arrière comme ça à ses arrières arrières
avec les deux capteurs le grand angle et
luttera lente angle je peux ensuite
passer au plat en mode incrustation moi
je suis tout petit justice y est comme
ça je me vois pratique je peux aussi
mettre le téléobjectif envoyé enfin ya
pas que l objectif mais je veux dire
zoomer en tout cas si je souhaite la et
venir à zoomer au max la très
honnêtement je pense pas que ce soit la
même idée on va rester comme ça c'est ce
qui ira le mieux ensuite je peux mettre
que l'arrière si je le souhaite voilà
cécile plus encore au tournage d'un
moment je ne vais que l'arrière et un
moment je ne mets que l'avant ça voyez
je préviens m'amuser fait simplement
donc ça c'est quand même pratique pense
que vous voulez venir faire des petits
effets on va sur le chrono prestation ça
c'est le tournage à pépé garcia comme ça
vous montrez ce cas devant vous êtes là
vous aussi est bon là c'est efficace et
ça marche mais je vais vous montrer un
truc là où on voit que l'algorithme et
force gardez là c'est complètement cramé
voyais au niveau du nuage ce fait la
photo je clique là je regarde et j'ai la
lgo qui va venir bosser et garder ça m'a
tout récupérer c'est assez dingue je
peux faire aussi sur le capteur
principal la bon ça va à peu près je
clique sur la photo je regarde et hop
vous allez voir il ya un traitement
qu'il a vraiment mal ténue et au niveau
des nuages et c'est là où on voit que la
go et parfois pour venir tout vous
corriger tout vous rattraper au niveau
des photos alors ces différents modes
vidéo qu'est ce qui vous permettent de
faire lors ce mode solo que je trouve
intéressant pour différentes choses
alors on parle beaucoup de tik tok on
parle des réseaux je suis d'accord mais
enfin vous voyez moi j'ai une
problématique lorsque par exemple papa
de famille lorsque je veux aller filmer
mon fils au spectacle de l'école et bien
je le filme comme ça j'ai tous les
enfants alors un mois nous aurons tout
le temps sur lui quelques h pour les
autres une mode solo coach il est
vachement cool pour ça parce qu'en fait
ce que je vais faire ce que je vais
prendre mon smartphone qui donc choisir
de filmer spécifiquement mon fils est là
donc les deux capteurs van bosselé il ya
un capteur qui va filmer la scène
globale et le deuxième capteur il a
filmé que mon fils comme ça je verrai
mon fils en détail si je le veux j'aurai
donc deux vidéos qui seront exportés à
partir du même moment je veux venir
filmer et je trouve que l'idée est
vachement cool alors il faut aller
jusqu'à 5 personnes max dont bon si on
fait un spectacle avec toute l'école ou
quand même que je reste quand même
resserré un petit peu sur lui ça peut
aussi marcher pour un concert si vous
voulez rester plus sur le guitariste par
exemple ça peut être pour un spectacle
de danse donc on va qui a tous ses
usages là qui sont assez marrant et que
au nord est venu vraiment mettre en
avant pour revenir chercher une cible
aux dix ans gardez vous avez cette
problématique on a les solutions voilà
ce qu'on est capable de faire parce
qu'il faut pas se mentir aujourd'hui
tous les constructeurs de smartphones
ont les mêmes processeurs ils ont les
mêmes technologies donc comment est ce
qu'on arrive à se différencier et bien
alors déjà par l'ensemble des composants
qu'on va venir battre à l'intérieur par
effectivement la marque qui des fois une
marque forte où il marque un peu moins
fort ça va dépendre bien évidemment de
la marque et si et ça ça va dépendre
aussi de toute l'expérience logiciel
mais surtout ça va dépendre par les
usages qu'ils vont mettre en avant d'un
point de vue marketing donc il vous
sortent des petites fonctionnalités un
peu marrant comme ça pour vous dire
regardez nous on sait faire ça s'adresse
pour vous et ça nous permet de
comprendre effectivement qui vient
cibler la marque ici on a une double
anneau sim 5g on a du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé et ce smartphone
existe dans deux configurations
828 8 256 828 vous avez de couleur vous
avez le vert ici vous avez la couleur
noire si maintenant vous le voulez en 8
256 vous aurez uniquement cette
couleur-là de disponibles et à 828 on
est à 549 euros et à 8 256 on est à 599
euros et c'est un smartphone qui est
disponible dès maintenant s'il vous
intéresse bien évidemment je mets les
liens en bas dans la description voilà
vous savez tout sur ceux au nord 70 ou
presque tous on se parle du mode solo
cad d'ici quelques jours j'espère que ça
vous aura intéressé surtout dites moi ce
que vous en pensez vous emmène à pau en
immersion à berlin comment vous le
trouvez ce smartphone est ce que vous le
trouver intéressant est ce que vous le
trouvez palpitant reste vous le trouvez
passionnant est ce que vous voulez mais
ce que vous ne l'aimez pas qu'est ce que
vous pensez de honor est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils sont sur la bonne voie en
tout cas il progresse énormément d'un
point de vue logiciel d'un point de vue
algorithmique d'un point de vue matériel
trouve ça assez lente donc dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez juste en bas
en commentaire on se retrouve dans
quelques jours quelques bonnes journées
elle est simplement le temps pour parler
du mode solo coeur de faire un tour
complet de la vidéo des différentes
fonctionnalités que nous propose ici et
bien on exclut au nord donc on en
reparle bientôt et puis là on élit phare
il ya plein de choses à raconter donc on
va continuer à parler tech bien
évidemment donc rester connecté regarder
ce qui se passe rester dans l'internet 1
comme on dit chez nous voilà donc je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt de shout
[Musique]